c'est particulièrement l'accueil ou
copains d'abord car qui dit 6 janvier 10
épiphanie toujours débordé beaucoup de
galettes de riz chaque année dans cette
boulangerie plusieurs centaines de
galettes trouvent preneurs
une tradition familiale que j'avais fils
aubin avec les enfants sont ils aiment
bien savoir qu'est-ce qui va voir qui tu
vas voir la fameuse pas et vous la
fameuse l'exploit tradition familiale
on crée beaucoup ça en france exactement
l'heure on l'exporté j'habite dans son
corps puis aujourd'hui toute légende
raconte se réunissent pour fêter libre
la tradition vient surtout d'europe et
en france chaque région a sa recette
bien à elle les galettes sur leur la
préparation de chaud le froid le four
qui sourd
arrivé au québec il ya quarante ans le
chef pâtissier marque qui éclot tente
d'offrir le meilleur de cet art aux
québécois de la brioche des fruits
confits envoyé ça sent bon l'europe ça
sent bon le citron il remarque un retour
en force de cette tradition au début de
mes activités ici qui ça fait quel un
chez marié stéphanie on faisait à peu
près de 300 galette et là on est rendu
presque à 2000
et comment expliquer cela on ne peut pas
une occasion pour pouvoir fêter alors
alors pourquoi pas y la galette c'est ce
qui se passe ici au québec et c'est
surtout l'occasion de porter le titre de
roi ou de reine pour la journée ici qui
me permettra au canada montréal